how did you get the reputation as
somebody that
doesn't for lack of a graduation doesn't
take from anybody
um from other writers from the industry
from like a michael ovitz at the time i
mean obvious was this this almighty
powerful
uh
creature
and you couldn't have cared less
well that's a very complicated question
you know it was right to the heart of
the beast
you know and uh
and that's a very difficult question
like
i've always believed in
in fighting
for my work
and with what comes out of my heart and
so
and then it's part of self-defense again
because i believe that
if you sell yourself out
these are children that we create these
are our children
almost not a spiritual level
even if you don't believe in
spirituality these are our children
and if we sell those children out
if we sell our own babies out and allow
ourselves to mutilate them
for commercial reasons and other reasons
and or re-mutilate them or kill them i
don't know how you look at yourself in
the mirror again it's a very personal
thing
but with me it's a question i'm looking
by something
you know if i am an accomplice
in killing my own child and i view it
that closely as my own child
and how do i write the next one
you know in terms of
my own
self-worth and all of that i
it's a very difficult proposition i
didn't i
we're all different and i understand
that and some of us may not feel the
same way
but i do his advice say to you
you're going to have a lot of problems
with your own work
if you sell yourself
you know we are all we all have our
worth and our
hearts and our soul
and then
if you sell yourselves out
you can cause yourself a lot of problems
and i don't want to be judgmental about
this with you
um
but but it doesn't make
writing is so goddamn difficult anyway
if you then if you
put these
blocks
in your in your heart
it's only going to make it more
difficult you know and then i really
have tried to avoid it for that reason
it is so that i don't have to deal with
those kinds of things i grew up
um
on the west side of cleveland refugee
i'm an immigrant
um yeah and then i had difficulties
growing up in in this new american world
and then the there was a there was a
little diner on the corner
called nick's diners right and i was a
refugee kid and there were all these
bullying american kids with
black leather jackets t-shirts rolled up
lucky
across the street to avoid them
essentially led them and then i realized
at some point that i was just running
away from them right so um
so i walked by them
and
and returned
that violence
and looking back on it now i think it's
the
absolute greatest training ground that i
have really